P
YOU INFORMED THROUGHOUT THIS
PIVOTAL MOMENT IN U.S. HISTORY.
MORE TERRORIST MISSILES.
THAT IS HOW UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT
IS DESCRIBING AN ATTACK ON
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS IN A CITY
IN CENTRAL UKRAINE.
OFFICIALS ARE REPORTING 11
PEOPLE KILLED, MORE THAN TWO
DOZEN INJURED.
THIS LATEST AERIAL ASSAULTS
HAPPENING IN BOTH RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE, OR AS BOTH RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE REPORT INTENSE FIGHTING
IN THE EASTERN DONETSK AND
SOUTHERN ZAPORIZHZHIA REGIONS.
SAM KILEY, BACK WITH US THIS
HOUR, FROM THE UKRAINIAN
CAPITAL.
IT'S VERY UNCLEAR AT THIS POINT,
AS TO WHETHER THIS --
MUCH ANTICIPATED COUNTER
OFFENSIVE --
YOU'VE BEEN ON THE GROUND FOR
WEEKS NOW OVER THIS CONFLICT.
IN YOUR ASSESSMENT, WHAT
EXACTLY IS GOING ON AT THIS
POINT?
AND WHAT ARE THE TACTICS HERE?
>> WELL I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
COUNTER OFFENSIVE, BECKY, YOU
ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT'S DELIBERATELY UNCLEAR.
A LACK OF CLARITY IN TERMS OF
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN IS EXACTLY
WHAT THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
THEY'VE EVEN GOT A CAMPAIGN
HERE TELLING PEOPLE TO KEEP IT
QUIET.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, IF WE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING ON, WE'VE SEEN THE
DESTABILIZING RAIDS BY
UKRAINIAN-BACKED RUSSIAN
DISSIDENTS INTO RUSSIA ITSELF.
WE HAVE SEEN THE LONG-RANGE
ATTACKS AGAINST THE RUSSIAN
LOGISTICS CHAIN HERE INSIDE
UKRAINE, AND MORE WIDELY INSIDE
RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
AND NOW WE ARE SEEING AN
INCREASED TEMPO OF ATTACKS IN
THAT SOUTHERN FRONT BETWEEN
ZAPORIZHZHIA, WHICH IS
UKRAINIAN-HELD, AND THE RUSSIAN
HELD CITY OF DONETSK, IN
PARTICULAR THAT SOUTHERN FRONT,
VERY VERY HEAVILY GUARDED AND
DEFENDED BY RUSSIA.
THE UKRAINIANS HAD LEFT IT
ALONE, NOW, FOR MANY MONTHS,
BUT THEY ARE NOW ATTACKING IT
WITH SOME FEROCITY.
NOT ON A MASSIVE SCALE, STILL
SORT OF, ONE LEVEL UP FROM THE
PROBING ATTACKS THAT WE HAD
SEEN BEFORE, BUT I THINK
DEFINITELY THEY ARE NOW INTENT
ON TRYING TO BREAKTHROUGH AND
HAVE CLAIMED SOME LIMITED
SUCCESS IN DOING THAT.
I THINK THAT'S THE SORT OF
BROADER PICTURE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE COUNTER OFFENSIVE,
CONCURRENT WITH THAT, AND
LIKELY TO BE WRAPPED INTO IT,
IF IT DEVELOPS FURTHER IN THE
FAVOR OF UKRAINE, IS THE
INCREASING ADVANCES THAT THEY
ARE MAKING TO THE SOUTHEAST OF
BAKHMUT.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF THE TROOPS IN
THAT REGION COULD JOIN UP WITH
THE ADVANCING RUSSIAN TROOPS,
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO START TO
APPROACH THE VERY HEAVILY
DEFENDED CITY OF DONETSK.
VERY MUCH A PRIZE OVER THE MUCH
LONGER TERM.
AS FAR AS THE UKRAINIANS ARE
CONCERNED.
BUT VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS JUST
COME OUT THE STATEMENT SAYING
THAT THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
NOVA KAKHOVKA DAM HAD,
UNFORTUNATELY, PERHAPS
IRONICALLY, SLOWED THE
UKRAINIAN OFFENSIVE PLANS.
THE FLOODING OF THE DNIPRO
RIVER VALLEY BELOW THE DAM HAS
MEANT THAT IT CAN'T BE USED,
WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS GOING TO
BE PART OF THE UKRAINIAN PLAN,
WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT IT DEFINITELY IS AN
IMPOSSIBLE NATURAL OBSTACLE
THAT IS VERY MUCH TO THE
ADVANTAGE OF THE RUSSIANS.
>> RAFAEL GROSSI, THE HEAD OF
THE U.N.'S SECURITY NUCLEAR
AGENCY IS IN UKRAINE.
WHAT IS HE DOING?
WHAT IS HE HOPING TO ACHIEVE?
>> HE HAS A NUMBER OF MONITORS
THAT ARE BASED PERMANENTLY,
THEY ROTATE, BUT THEY ARE A
PERMANENT PRESENCE OF THE IAEA
AT THE ZAPORIZHZHIA NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT STATION, WHICH IS
WHEN IT'S AT FULL CAPACITY, THE
LARGEST NUCLEAR POWER STATION
IN THE WHOLE OF EUROPE.
IT'S ONLY GOT ONE REACTOR,
WHICH IS IN A --
SHUT DOWN, ALL THE OTHERS HAVE
BEEN SHUT DOWN.
THERE ISN'T, AT THE MOMENT, A
CONCERN THAT THERE IS A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO THE
NUCLEAR POWER STATION IN TERMS
OF ACCESS TO THE COOLING WATERS
FROM THAT DAN, ABOVE THE NOW
BURST NOVA KAKHOVKA DOWN.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A COOLING
POND THAT IS CAPABLE OF LASTING
SEVERAL MONTHS.
BUT THEY WILL HAVE TO REFILL IT,
THE WATER IS DROPPING QUICKLY,
THERE ARE CONCERNS WON'T BE
POSSIBLE TO REFILL IT.
THAT IS THE EFFECT OF THE DAM,
BUT AT THE SAME, TIME THIS IS A
FRONTLINE POSITIONS, BECKY, HE
WILL BE SEEKING REASSURANCES
FROM THE UKRAINIANS AND, NO
DOUBT, FROM THE RUSSIANS.
THAT THEY AREN'T GOING TO GET
INTO A FIGHT INSIDE A NUCLEAR
POWER STATION.
NOW, THE RUSSIANS FOUGHT THEIR
WAY INTO THAT NUCLEAR POWER
STATION, WHICH WAS A PANDA AND
BY THE UKRAINIAN FORCES RATHER
THAN HAVE A SERIOUS BATTLE OVER
A NUCLEAR INSTALLATION THAT WAS
RUNNING AT A MUCH HIGHER
CAPACITY BACK IN MARCH LAST
YEAR.
THERE HAVE BEEN ASSURANCES
GIVEN BY BOTH SIDES THAT THEY
WOULD DEMILITARIZED THIS AREA
ULTIMATELY, PERHAPS, BUT IT IS
STILL A RUSSIAN BASE.
IT IS STILL USED BY THE
RUSSIANS TO ATTACK CIVILIAN
TARGETS IN PARTICULAR.
BUT MILITARY TO, ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE DNIPRO RIVER.
AND, AS THE UKRAINIANS PUSH
SOUTH, IF THEY'RE CAPABLE OF
DOING THAT FROM SEPARATES THE
CITY, AND EVERY INDICATION THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
DO, CLEARLY THE PRESENCE OF A
NUCLEAR POWER STATION BASICALLY
ON THE FRONT LINE IS GOING TO
ABSOLUTELY BE TOP OF THE IAEA'S
AGENDA.